foreign
[Music]
for keynotech news Sylvester Stallone
speaks out about Rambo 6 Johnny Depp
stars and Beetlejuice 2 and the Star
Wars series Lando gets a total revamp
this and much more awaits you in this
week's video enjoy
news from the trolls after the Norwegian
monster movie troll wowed viewers in
2022 and became one of the most popular
non-english films of all time Netflix
has now officially greenlit a sequel
Norwegian director Roar Utah who has
already demonstrated his talent for
great destruction in films like the wave
seems to have made a lasting impression
on Netflix with his monster movie troll
as the movie was able to convince with
phenomenal viewing figures accordingly
it should come as no surprise that the
streaming service has now announced a
sequel as variety reports the sequel has
already been ordered Roar utag will
again be in charge of directing and
writing the screenplay for the adventure
the director expressed his Joy at the
announcement and sees it as confirmation
that the hard work on the first part was
fully paid off making troll was a
lifelong dream come true and the
reception hour Norwegian movie has
received around the world has been
unbelievable Troll 2 could seamlessly
follow on from its predecessor however
it might not be the only troll that that
is wreaking havoc in the mountains of
Norway after all the fans are supposed
to get their money's worth in terms of
spectacle in action and so it could be
that this time Utah will unleash a whole
bunch of destructive trolls on beautiful
Norway either way we are really looking
forward to it
Disney cancels the Lando series a few
months ago it was announced that the
popular Gambler would return in his own
Star Wars series however these plans
have been scrapped because instead of a
series a Lando movie is now to be
released instead due to the flop of solo
a Star Wars story many ideas for Planned
prequels and spin-off films from the
Star Wars Universe were put on hold this
also led to the fact that things got
quiet around an own Lando adventure with
Donald Glover at first in July of this
year however the project came back to
life as Lando was to be given his own
series instead of a film however these
plans seem to be off the table again as
Stephen Glover who was to direct the
series announced in the podcast Pablo
Tori finds out a movie is now planned
after all whether it will be produced
for the big screen or just for the
Disney plus streaming service remains
unclear similarly there is no
information about a release date still
it can be assumed that the Glover
Brothers will also be responsible for
the film and that Donald Glover will
once again embody the titular character
Lando calriss in another interview with
vulture Stephen Glover said that Donald
had emphasized the importance to him of
pushing Innovation and not being
constricted by the limitations of the
studio system so it seems that they
intend to implement their own and
particularly Creative Vision regarding
the character with the planned movie The
Lando project will be part of a whole
series of Star Wars films that Disney
currently has up its sleeve in addition
to Star Wars 10 New Jedi Order with
Daisy Ridley as Rey Skywalker there will
also be a film by taika waititi a
prequel about the first Jedi by James
Mangold and a Trilogy by Ryan Johnson
Rambo is so famous that his name has
even made it into the dictionary the
role is immortally linked to Sylvester
Stallone but he's not getting any
younger now the actor has spoken out at
the Toronto Film Festival about a
possible sixth part in the series Rambo
5 last Blood the final part of the
popular Rambo series for the time being
was released in 2019 but it fell short
of expectations the action film received
catastrophic reviews and also failed to
live up to its predecessor Rambo 4 with
a worldwide box office result of 90
million dollars since then it's been
quiet around the movie series in the
recent Festival interview Stallone
expressed a little motivation for a
return to the character in another solo
film Rambo I could leave him he's done
pretty much even though they want to do
another one but what am I fighting
arthritis with this Stallone may have
expressed exactly what some of his fans
are feeling as they have been vocal
about the fact that the character should
finally enjoy his retirement after the
fifth part however Stallone also
reported that plans for another Rambo
film are currently being worked on he
did have a prequel about the Vietnam War
in mind in which the role of John Rambo
would be played by another actor but
according to the latest plans there will
be some kind of sequel which will be
about a potential successor to Stallone
according to him the Studio's intention
is for him to pass the torch in this
film so it looks like John Rambo will
return one last time to pass the Baton
to the Next Generation we are looking
forward to more news and we'll keep you
posted
it would be a sensation according to
reports director Tim Burton has cast
none other than Johnny Depp in an
unknown role for his sequel Beetlejuice
2. his involvement in the second story
of the scary comedy would thus represent
the ninth collaboration between the two
according to Giant freaking robot Johnny
Depp is said to be part of the cast of
Beetlejuice 2 and could thus celebrate
his comeback in a major Hollywood
production in the wake of the media war
with his ex-wife Amber Heard Depp
initially fell out of favor with film
studios and was seen less and less often
in prominent roles already in November
of last year Tim Burton expressed his
interest in a new collaboration with
Johnny Depp to the Reuters agency he
left open however which project it would
be the last collaboration of the two was
the 2012 released vampire comedy Dark
Shadows more than 11 years ago now it
sounds like they found a good
opportunity to team up again with the
sequel to The 1988 classic Beetlejuice
however it remains unclear in which role
death will return according to the
latest casting report the ACT will make
a cameo appearance which means his role
is unlikely to be a big one in addition
to Johnny Depp Batman star Michael
Keaton will be seen in the lead role as
well as Winona Ryder and Wednesday star
Jenna Ortega Beetlejuice 2 will be
released on September 6 2024.
the Toxic Avenger is considered one of
the most unusual heroes in the history
of Cinema and as a cult figure
especially among fans of the trash genre
now a reboot with Game of Thrones star
Peter Dinklage in the leading role is
being released and new images present us
with a cast that is well worth having a
look at the Toxic Avenger reboot
celebrated its World premiere on
September 21st in the context of the
Austin fantastic Fest on this occasion
Entertainment Weekly has now published a
series of new images that may put you in
the mood for the Trashy spectacle Elijah
Wood who will embody the movie's villain
and leave a lasting impression deserves
a special mention here the look of the
character is likely to be reminiscent of
the penguin embodied by Danny DeVito in
Tim Burton's Batman Returns this is no
coincidence according to director
Malcolm Blair the character was actually
inspired by it along with a touch of The
Rocky Horror Picture Show likewise we
get a look at Peter dinkwich he wears a
suit coat a black mask and a pink ballet
tutu a teaser of the film's peculiar
tone Jake of Tremblay Taylor Page and
Kevin Bacon are also introduced as well
as a bunch of masks and armed men these
in turn are somewhat reminiscent of The
Purge series or Todd Phillips Joker when
it comes to violence and nastiness the
reboot won't spare anyone either after
all the film was given an R rating for
abundant violence nudity profanity and
sexual innuendo very much in keeping
with the tradition of its predecessors
the Toxic Avenger is currently being
screened at various International
festivals we can can't wait to find out
whether the star-studded trash film will
make its way into theaters
the end for El muerto Sony's Spider-Man
universe was supposed to expand with the
planned Solo movie of the villain
however nothing will come a bit for the
time being as the main actor left the
project Sony Spider-Man universe is
booming and fans can look forward to a
whole series of new projects next year
in addition to the third part of Tom
Hardy's Venom the eagerly awaited Craven
the hunter will follow likewise Madam
Webb embodied by Dakota Johnson will
make her debut next year besides these
movies however a rather unknown villain
was to get his own big screen appearance
namely Juan Carlos Sanchez Alias El
muerto the masked wrestler with
superhuman abilities was to be played by
singer and bullet train star Bad Bunny
who has now unexpectedly left the
project the actor's decision was met
with surprise because after all Bunny
always raved about his role in an
interview with comicbook.com for example
he announced that he wanted to make
people proud and that he was very happy
regarding his character however rumors
also regularly made the rounds that
there had been disagreements between him
and the studio the current actor strike
might also have contributed to this
since the film was actually supposed to
start its production this summer so it
remains unclear for now whether we will
actually see El muerto on the big screen
in the near future and who will play him
in the end
that's it for this week's news and here
is our next cinema highlights if you're
interested in Transformers 1 releasing
in 2024 or a leader battle Angel 2 you
shouldn't miss our latest movie previews
here on our Channel we thank you for
watching and see you next week for more
Hollywood news
[Music]
thank you